living in this flat feels
terrifying i'm spending every single
waking moment
worrying that i'm either going to burn
to death in my bed at night
or that i could lose everything that
i've worked and saved so hard for it's
just not fair
this is natasha her block of flats in
manchester
is such a fire risk residents have to
pay for a 24-hour watch
it's not just the cladding that's a fire
risk here it's the insulation in the
walls
the decking and balconies you know
essentially i'm living
in a flammable prison you know it feels
like i've had every option taken from me
through no fault of my own and you know
i want to move on and start a family
and have children i can't morally bring
them up in this flat when i know that
it's a fire risk
to remove the cladding alone would cost
each resident
38 000 pounds the government has long
promised help
and today residents found out what was
on offer
further funding available to pay for the
removal and replacement
of unsafe cladding for all leaseholders
in high-rise
residential buildings of 18 meters and
above
or above six stories in england
we continue to take a safety led
approach
so what does that mean for people like
natasha well because her block is 19
meters tall she will be able to get a
grant to remove cladding
but she'll have to pay for all other
works the fire wardens and insurance
which costs
thousands but she is still better off
than charlotte who lives in a nearby
block
her building is 15 meters high that
means
no grant but a loan for cladding and
like natasha
no money to cover additional costs
everything i have is in this property
at the moment it's worth zero pounds so
all of that money that i invested
into a property is effectively at the
moment worth
nothing and i'm a little bit worried
that the cost of the actual remediation
could end up being more than the deposit
on the flight in the first place
which begs the question of what was
actually the point in becoming a
first-time buyer
it's estimated there are a million
people
living in flats with some sort of fire
safety risk
and it would cost 15 billion pounds to
fix them all
now the government's fund promises 5
billion to help people
that's a 10 billion pound shortfall with
no clear answer
as to where that money comes from the
government has said it will make
developers pay but how much is uncertain
after years of being promised help
people here
aren't holding out much hope catherine
of autopsy sky news in manchester